hey kayla what's going on i recently
brought up charges against my cousin
for repeatedly sexually abusing me 32
years ago
okay so what what brought you to this
decision
well hold on let me stop for let me stop
for a second
i should have said this before that
you're brave
you're a a lion and i'm proud to know
you
kayla i appreciate it i had to do it it
was something i
i had to do to protect other girls
good for you man that's hard hard hard
stuff and that choice is yours
and i'm proud of you for making the
choice that was right for you all right
so
now tell me about what it's been like
okay so um he repeatedly sexually abused
me when i was five years old
in 1988 and i never told any anybody
until i was 12 years old i told my mom
and dad
but my entire family they they all knew
about it but they just swept it under
the rug
pretending nothing ever happened nothing
well
fast forward about 20 years
and he or 15 20 years he got charged 10
years ago for sexually abusing his
stepdaughter
and he only did six months in jail and
was released
well three years ago he got charged for
doing it to his biological daughter
but the charges got dismissed because
she was afraid to testify
on the stand against him well when i
read the article
two years ago about that and i found out
that he'd been
charged for uh doing it to his
biological daughter too
i just like snapped and i had to come
forward
and tell my story to an investigator
because somebody needed to stand up
against him and
um and that's what i did and he picked
up
multiple charges of first-degree
felonies and he's been sitting in jail
for a year and a half
awaiting trial but this has caused
a big can of worms to open in my family
especially with his mother
who's my aunt and his sisters who are my
cousins
they ref they hate my guts now they
refuse to talk to me hey you know what
caleb
ridiculous i don't i they're not worth
the air you breathe
they're not worth the air you breathe
your parents left you as a child high
and dry
there's predators and pieces of crap
everywhere that's life
it sucks but that's life and we do what
we can to keep them off the streets
that's why we have parents that's why we
have cousins
that's why we have aunts and uncles
that's why we have friends and community
members and church members and people
who've got our backs
and yours let you down and so
how dare they circle back and try to
roll this over on you
no no
so then i just um i just uh
just have it they're out of my life for
good not by your hand and just leave it
that way what
like kayla they walked away from you
right they chose a child molester over
somebody who was
injured somebody who was hurt for years
and they did it for years and then they
allowed it caused other girls to get
hurt
yes they cho you don't want to associate
with them anyway
yeah well i i don't i just i wish i
could
conk him over the head so that he had
some common sense listen
you can't they're not going to they're
never going to anybody's going to stand
up for a repeat
child molester is not something that you
can solve
right you dust your dirt off your
sandals and you walk out
and i know that's heartbreaking and
that's lonely not because of
them per se but because now you're
lonely
now there's consequences to your
boundaries and that's
hard and i get that but i'm just telling
you as a
as a dad of a daughter thank you for
being bold
and brave and strong even though it's 20
years
thank you thank you for keeping that
piece of garbage off the street
once my daughter turned five that's when
this all like
opened up inside me that i couldn't stop
anymore like i had to do something
that's exactly right your body's alarms
go off because it sees another it's easy
you
walking right in front of it right every
morning at breakfast time it sees it
right yeah yeah so
so do you have any advice for me um how
what would be the best like what should
i do
to um this is a going a giant step
towards healing
of him finally being in jail and being
off the streets and
you know hopefully he gets convicted and
does a long long time yeah but um
what um advice do you have for me to
fully heal from this so i i'm going to
give you a statement a comment about
the the jail part that um i testified
against somebody in jail once
um that committed a crime and they got a
lot of
um it was it was a pretty ugly crime and
they got a lot of jail time
and i called a friend of mine she's a
mentor of mine she's a
psychologist who works with abused kids
and when the verdict was read the next
day i felt sick
and i thought i would feel awesome like
yeah that's what's up
and i felt gross i felt terrible like
just
gross and i called her and said i don't
understand these feelings
and she said john nobody wins
everybody's life is destroyed with with
childhood sexual abuse
everyone yeah right and so
you will there will be a level of safety
to where hey this person can't get to me
anymore and that's real and good
and there might be that cheery like yeah
moment
if there's a verdict that comes down
but i don't want you to think you're
gonna feel good
well i haven't felt great through the
whole process
the whole thing is awful right and so
here's the first question and this is an
important question and i
i'm asking this because i love you not
not as a way of poking okay
and there's times um that this question
gets asked and people can weaponize the
way they they
ask this and i'm not doing that okay i'm
i'm with you on this conversation okay
okay are you ready to be done with this
and here's here before you answer here's
what i mean
we hang on when we loop the story when
we
hang on to it tight it feels like
protection it feels like hyper vigilance
it feels like
nobody's gonna ever get me again i'll be
damned if i'm gonna let that happen
no one's coming for me no one's gonna if
they do they're gonna there's gonna be
there's gonna be hell to pay right
it feels like this stressed alert
vigilant
like i am i am protecting myself i'm
protecting my daughter
and that keeps you alive now and it
kills you tomorrow
that level of stress circulation that
level of vigilance always on always on
always on
wears out your your adrenaline and your
cortisol
it just slowly grinds your body down and
so when i ask you
are you ready to be done that means
not i'm ready to just um go have an
abusive situation again no
are you ready to stop carrying this guy
in your backpack
this brick yes
i'm ready to stop carrying it and the
five-year-old inside of me had to come
forward and
get some justice to finish it off and
now i want her to be able to go
be a five-year-old right
right and i want you to be able to raise
your was she six seven eight nine now
your daughter and let her have the fun
joyful like learn how to be a strong
powerful woman like her mom i want her
to be able to
like have that world right and so here's
a couple of things you can do to help
to heal right number one real important
is to become aware of your body's
response the physical part of it
and learn to honor it and let it
complete the cycles right and that's
from
emily nagatsuki's new work i love it um
but it's this idea of
when you feel your heart start racing
when you feel those those thoughts start
looping on you and your hands get
cl whatever it is with that you feel
right when you're in the presence of
somebody
a guy that makes you feel uncomfortable
when you find yourself here or there
you you know that kicks in right
when you yeah notice that and begin to
honor that oh here it goes man my body's
trying to protect me
and you can slowly distance yourself
from it not as a thing that you
are but it's just a thing that's
happening in your body and then you can
begin to ask
hey what's it trying to protect me from
oh that guy's safe
he's all right i know that guy he's
goofy and he's silly and his jeans are
way too tight he's got a mustache but i
like that guy right so
it's beginning it's becoming aware of
how your body's responding
right and then when it does take off on
you do you have
anxiety attacks or panic attacks or do
you have moments of rage like what what
what still
how does it emerge in your body this
many years later
um i'm not really anxiety or rage like i
think i'm
past all that because you know so many
years
so but i've just been wanting it to be
like
i feel like um
it's hard to explain um
i just feel like the the the little girl
that was inside of me that
that happened to the five-year-old she
needs to be heard
and and she needs somebody to listen
damn so here's what i want you to do
will you do me this favor
i want you to write that five-year-old
girl a letter
and from i want you to write her three
letters okay
are you ready yeah letter number one
is gonna be the letter from your parents
what they should have said
okay okay and i want you to write a
letter
from you to her letting her know that
what happened is not okay
and that you're so sorry that nobody
protected her when they should have
but now you're going to
okay and then the third letter is i want
you to write her a letter letting her
know
who you're going to become how you're
going to make meaning of this this many
years later what kind of mom you're
going to be
what kind of professional you're going
to be what kind of community
and neighbor you're going to be
and then get into that sounds like a
good idea i want you to let that girl go
i want you to let her
go go play
okay okay i really appreciate you
talking to me no i appreciate you
calling and here here's
here's um are you married now
yeah i just recently got married okay
and i'm
pregnant with uh my fourth baby hey
there you go
fourth man you're you're a bad man
pajama all right
here's what i want you to do and this is
going to be a bold step for you okay
this new guy he's all right oh he's
wonderful
okay so here is the evil
beyond the evil there's 18 layers of
evil with childhood abuse
18 layers of just demo that's why it
rages through family genera like
linny just for years it's because the
only thing that keeps a person well
and whole insane and alive
is vulnerable connection to other people
in childhood sexual abuse particularly
tells a child that safe relationships
don't exist
and in fact relationship is the core
of the worst pain you can experience
and so what you're gonna have to do at
your as as a
about to be mama of four is you're gonna
have to
learn how to be in relationship
how to roll over and expose your belly
again
be vulnerable again and risk getting
hurt again
because that's the only way you're going
to be fully vested with this new
knucklehead you just married
and what you're going to have and here's
the thing that makes sense it's scary
and it's hard and here's the thing i
want you to hear me say
you got to practice it it's something
you learn how to do
we think we just know how to do
relationships we don't we all suck at it
we're terrible and so if you go into it
saying hey honey we're going to take
dancing lessons
or we're going to learn how to build a
cabinet we're going to go to this little
class with the ymca
how to build a cabinet that's what
you're doing but i want you to tell them
i want to be so plugged in with you
and that starts with me learning how to
heal
with me saying i'm never carrying this
dude's crap for another
second i'm gonna do the work i'm gonna
write the letters and let this
five-year-old girl go be
and then bubba you don't even know
what's coming for you
right i'm gonna love you in a way that
you ain't ever been loved and i'm
expecting you to love me back that way
and that's just something we got to
practice and learn together
right well that sounds great and we both
deserve it
hey you do kayla you super dude
what's his name trent
kaitlyn trent that just sounds romantic
kayla and trent
both of you deserve it and
um my heart tells me you just got to
learn it
and that's okay and that's so good
you're it's give me 70
and be like you know what i'ma learn how
to do vulnerable connection because i'm
going to have the last 20 years of my
life
be intertwined with other people good
for you kayla
good for you you are a brave powerful
lion
cheetah awesome stud woman i'm so proud
of you
and um i can't wait to hear how this
goes let me know how
how it goes after you write those
letters let me know what kind of
relationship counseling you get into you
and trent
big t and let us know when that fourth
baby's born and we'll celebrate here on
the show thank you so much for your call
kayla thanks for being brave